what are your proudest accomplishments
my two sons Bodhi Elfman and Louie
Elfman my daughter Audrey Elfman a a lot
of stage productions and events that
aren't recorded Forbidden Zone and about
to come out hipsters gangsters aliens
and geeks and at least the script I've
got for Forbidden Zone - and the music
that's being written for it you said
something interesting you said a bunch
of events and stage productions that
have not been recorded yeah so how do
you think we operate now as a society
because it's like we see something
amazing first thing you have to do is
film it with our phone and it takes us
out of the moment
well there's something I mean the
difference between stage and theater
there's something about stage that's
incomparable
that biofeedback the audience right
there
but what happened Forbidden Zone was
really just my stage show that I wanted
to capture on film not the same the the
something that happens with theatre
that's incomparable but the nice thing
about film you get hit by a truck and
someone could see it a hundred years
later that's the truck girls down at
least they'll see my films right the
thing about theater is there's the
chance that something could go wrong
and I think that anticipation and we
want to know how are the actors going to
handle that shows get to a certain point
that they just meld with it you just
meld with it it's hard to describe it's
something someone can forget a line and
the other guy just picks up audience
never knows you know like after you've
played a month in our French troupe
we'll drum savvier he's he was my mentor
II passed away a few years ago drank a
bit so right in the middle here's 800
people and I got my brother into the
troupe to play violin that our violinist
was originally from the French opera
couldn't deviate from the score
and we'd like to do a little bit of
improv with the music so Danny got the
role for a summer so right in the middle
of a scene then Jerome was in it he just
runs out and the actors are standing
there and here's 800 people what we
gonna do so I just go over with Danny
and we improvised for 5 7 minutes and
the audience is chanting he's on his
electric violin I'm on my Tim Bali's
barely Jerome had had too much to drink
got sick came back picked up the play
I've seen people fall down and break
ribs and fingers finish the scene and
then go offstage and collapse just like
I went two routes with a broken thumb
you do what you have to do do you
operate from intuition mostly to a large
degree to a large degree but uh I always
like other opinions before I have a
finished product you know like what the
film I've got to have input you know I
test things want to know what the editor
thinks I want to know what the
cinematographer thinks you know so it's
not like complete blinders does that
sometimes get you in trouble because
Pete you know something's going to be a
certain way and other people go know and
then it turns out you were right yeah
and they go wait how'd he know that you
know it's also because a film you can't
really judge you know that's completely
complete and people force you to see
rough so rough cuts or this or that and
there's no way to get them to see it
until it's done but sometimes you're
forced to let them see it in order to
get it done the irony has your intuition
always been strong yeah even when you
were kid I go with the gut mm-hmm does
that make people mad sometimes because
you're right Nate they get offended they
get upset know if it's a winner then
they all want to sign on
okay take as much credit as they can
what about with boxing how did you use
your intuition with boxing I don't think
I use it I was like this as generally
the only white guy in the gym I hit like
a mule and when I wasn't the most
finesse aful boxer so I don't know if it
was intuition it was more like just I I
wasn't floyd mayweather but you're
obviously still here so something worked
yeah I'm a little bit of a hard time
making you turds because of the stress
fractures of the neck but no I've been
good shape I'm a good shape you still
want a box no you still want to throw
somebody in a pool
occasionally Oh although I don't do that
anymore okay
I'm more behaved right yeah I know the
real estate market and drop sure sure
but it'll come back yeah in LA it always
comes back last question is if you could
hold a dinner party for ten deceased
people and have them come back like say
you do a seance or something they would
manifest who would they be
Duke Ellington Cab Calloway say Leah
Cruise Alfred Hitchcock Oscar Wilde
God how many are we oh five God tell me
Mark Twain
Oh God my parents I'll start crying okay
all right so that number then we have
two more after start crying oh yeah big
directors
Charlie Chaplin and Stan Laurel who
produced all of Laurel and Hardy what
would you serve Oh maybe what I served
last night I got local branzino
slathered it with a spicy cilantro chili
grilled it with on with a fennel it's
very good with fennel and got an
exquisite Veon yay a little bit above my
price range but the bouquet is perfect
so that's what I had for the first
course for the second course I just got
simple prime New York steak crushed a
ton of fresh garlic cooked it perfectly
but the garlic and the butter to drizzle
over it and then I grilled onions
portabellos red and yellow peppers
Anaheim peppers and so they had fresh
vegetables and we had that with I people
from Barcelona so we had a priori 't red
wine from catalonia excellent and then
we had vintage port with the cheese
course so that's what I served last
night that might do and what would be
the topic of conversation that this does
oh it'd be all kinds of topics how would
you start it off I wouldn't even need to
start it off they'd start themselves I
got to say the greatest dinner parties
are often loud because people are
talking people are talking they're
communicating and the the room was only
lit by fire and candles and then we
finished upstairs I have a fireplace on
the deck for the cognac and cigars and
we have cigars of all different types by
the way my wife had never had a smoke a
puff of smoke in her life and although I
had permission to smoke cigars it was
like shower twice if I wanted to kiss in
bed afterwards but I finally found
something that was so deliciously
perfumed and
matic that she'll have one now and it's
a now a couple activity that we do and
she loves the way it looks with her
fingernails in a cigar you know kind of
odd breaking the mold of oh sure
girliness yeah is very dramatic yeah do
you have a no cell phone rule when you
have these dinner parties or that
doesn't matter no one uses their cell
phone people take pictures sometimes now
I say that's a new sort of no no rules
conversation of etiquette like well I do
have rules sometimes they have to wear
hats oh I saw the Fez out there yeah and
keep your shoes on okay any absolute no
nose anything goes uh no no no no III
like fun fun parties where people get to
relax and be themselves I do it
directors night once a month what is
that I have film directors over get
drunk smoke cigars got some hot lady
directors now - oh it is exciting in the
horror community we've got some very
interesting what's happening now so are
you talking about film when you have
these directors around or or is it
completely not about film life in some
film sure you know people compare notes
more story supposed to just life what's
going on and you do this once a month
with these directors yeah I probably
have dinners dinner parties least twice
a month
directors thing once a month sounds fun
oh yeah
you